okay let's get started
good morning my name is lou d'andrea i'm
an interface developer at wolfram
research and today i'm going to talk to
you about
building contextual interfaces uh if you
were
at john fultz's state of the front end
talk earlier today you've seen
some of what i'm going to show um i'm
going to talk about contextual
interfaces
that you have seen already in our
product for some number of years
in fact for the last decade or so i
think eight years
we've been showing various kinds of
attached interfaces so i'm going to
survey some of them here
we have the ability to overlay an
interface for
showing you uh completions for when
you're typing
code we have an overlay
a an attached interface whenever you
click on
a bitmap image in the front end you
automatically get
image editing tools notice how these
tools are overlaying the notebook
content
we a lot of this technology was
developed initially
for the predictive interface the
suggestions bar so here we have an
attached interface
and here we have an attached interface
notice that this interface goes away
comes back exactly like the image editor
goes away and comes back exactly when
you need it
and some other attached interfaces that
maybe you didn't realize were using the
same technology so control equal
has an assumptions button and that
assumptions feature
throws up some an interface in a
place that looks sort of like a tool tip
but is interactive
in our message support we've uh
recently added the ability to show stack
traces
and the stack trace is shown as part of
as one of these you know contextual
interfaces with the ability to make it
into a real notebook
and lots of others uh a mesh editor
that's a lot image editors
i'm not going to itemize every single
one we've got some new ones coming in
12-2 in particular
noah hardwick is giving a talk
immediately following this talk
on the canvas feature uh that stephen
has demoed and john fultz has demoed
um and noah's gonna talk a little bit
more in depth about
some of the issues surrounding that so
i'd encourage you to take a look at that
talk
but this is the state of attached
interfaces so
um one of the things that we want to do
is wrap this up
in a nice little box with the bow and to
give users the ability to build these
interfaces themselves
so what did we want to do with the
thing that we give users well we wanted
the ability to attach
anything any display any cell to any
object in the front end
be it a box cell cell bracket a piece of
a notebook
etc we wanted those attached cells to
not
dirty the notebook we didn't want them
to get into cell expressions or notebook
expressions
not be saved with a notebook etc we
wanted to make sure that we could use
the full richness of the wolfram
language control
language so input fields sliders all
manner of dynamics
graphics etc we wanted the ability to
skew
obscure other notebook content so the
attach cell wouldn't have to worry about
fighting with user content for being
able to be seen
and we wanted styling to sort of be
automatic but
obviously you can do all kinds of things
with with styles
and we wanted them to be chained
chainable so you can have an attached
interface
that can attach uh things to itself
um what are some of the results of these
design goals well
since they're not part of the notebook
model they're not saved with the
notebook that means they're not going to
travel with copy and paste
either this is a good thing we don't
want interfaces
propagating unnecessarily because
they're drawn on top of notebook content
that means that they're going to catch
mouse clicks that means even invisible
attached cells or the invisible corners
of attached cells are going to obscure
things
and if you have multiple attach cells
that want to be attached at the same
point
you might get a little bit of chaos as
the transparency shows multiple attach
attachments um so something to keep in
mind
also they render the attach cells render
in the space of the
of the notebook window so if the attach
cell wants to be wider than the notebook
window you're not going to see the piece
that that
spills off the side and
just sort of uh the usual kinds of
concerns if you have a
attached cell being spawned from a
dynamic module box you're going to need
to
to learn about wormholes or if you know
about wormholes you're going to have to
extend that knowledge
to to attach cells
so what is the thing we built so in 12-2
those of you that have the the
conference beta or
some pre-release build in the last i
don't know a few weeks
will have access to this by the way this
notebook that i'm presenting from is
already on the conference site feel free
to download it
and use it if you have a new enough
build of 12-2
or save it for when 12-2 comes out so
that you can refresh your memory as to
what this talk was about
so simplest form we want to attach
an expression so here we have we're
attaching
an expression where does it attach well
by convention it's going to attach
to the cell that evaluated so i evaluate
this
it attaches this hello world within the
sort of spatial region of the cell that
it's attaching to
and the attached cell function call
returns a handle
to that attached cell
and this can be used in lots of
different ways and i'll see some of
those i'll show some of those ways a
little bit later
let's grind through the syntax so that's
the one argument form two argument form
lets you specify what you want to attach
to
so you can attach to a notebook object
cell object or
box object if you don't know what these
things are i'll talk about those in
depth in just a minute
so here we have i'm going to show an
example of attaching not to the cell
it's evaluating
and not to the cell before it but to the
cell before that cell so the heading
cell
i'm going to attach something and the
reason i chose that cell is that that
cell has a font color
and notice that the attach cell
inherited that font color
so the attach cell is going to inherit
some bits of the styling of the cell
it's attached to
you can think of the styling of an
attached cell the same way you would
think of
the styling of an inline cell those are
the kinds of inheritance that we're
talking about
so you can optionally specify a location
in the object to which to attach so we
can say
attach to that heading cell but instead
of doing the default location
attach at the right edge of this cell
so if i evaluate this it's going to show
the attachment happens at the right edge
of that cell and you can specify any of
the sort of important points around the
perimeter
you know center top left bottom etc and
we'll take a look at some other
positions some special positions
later on so you can also specify a
location
in the attack in the thing you're
attaching so
uh those of you familiar with inset
you'll be familiar with the pause
oh pause notation so the position in the
object should align with
this position in the thing you're
attaching
um so here i have a simple
academic example of a box
for which i have a box object and i'll
i'll show this a little bit later
so we have a we have a reference to this
box and i want to attach
uh a red square to that box object
so the upper right corner of the object
here should align with the upper right
corner of the box i'm attaching
and so here we have the ability to do
that kind of alignment
i'm going to attach a green box now at
the same point in the in the object
but i'm going to attach it at its left
bottom corner
so we evaluate that and we see that the
green box has attached at its
left bottom corner notice that it's
overlaying other notebook content
um and a blue box i'm going to use the
uh the distance specification to say
attach at the left bottom corner of the
blue box
but at a distance of a hundred uh points
from
the right top of the gray box and here
the blue one
is uh another stair step away
so uh i've included in this notebook a
manipulate for
you to investigate different pause oh
pause positions
uh that is for you to play with once
12-2
once you have 12-2 take a look at this
notebook and
see what you think so the last thing
i'll mention
is how to the syntax related to deleting
attach cells so
we have uh the ability to delete attach
cells manually here is a simple
if annoying attached cell attached to
the notebook um
return to cell object one way to delete
an attached cell is to call
notebook delete on that object so here
we call notebook delete and the
and that annoying attached cell goes
away um
but we have some an option removal
condition
um sorry plural removal conditions that
lets you specify
a list of conditions that will cause
this attach cell to automatically delete
um so we can delete automatically
whenever the kernel quits for instance
or whenever the mouse leaves
this example uses the mouse click
outside feature so so
we don't need to specify another
interface element that the user
interacts with
in order to close this we can just have
them click anywhere and
the attach cell goes away so very useful
um this is all documented i don't know
if the documentation for it made its way
into the conference beta but it
certainly will be in the final build of
12 2.
so let's walk through the attachment
points cell object box object
notebook object you might be familiar
already with cell
objects we developed those uh when we
were developing the projective interface
a cell object is a reference to a
particular cell
in the front end we have ways of
extracting lists of them or
individual cell objects uh those of you
unfamiliar with these
can use this as a jumping off point to
learn about cell objects
but as far as attach cell and how it
interacts with
cell objects well the first thing to
notice is that the attached cell
returns the object so here i have a
button
we're attaching to this evaluation cell
and this button is going to delete
the object corresponding to the attached
cell so it's a button in the attach cell
that deletes the attached cell
you click that and the button and the
cell contains
disappear the thing i want to point out
is you don't need to remember this box
object
sorry the cell object from within the
attach cell display
you can instead use evaluation cell as a
reference
inside of the attached cell evaluation
cell refers to
the attached cell so here we're
attaching
to the cell i'm shift entering a button
which deletes
the evaluation cell of that button which
is the attached cell
so this again deletes the attached cell
and of course you could walk up the the
cell object chain to the parent cell of
the attached cell
in this case that's the cell that i just
evaluated
so here we have an attached cell that
when clicked is going to delete
this this this top level in 17 cell
so it can very definitely affect
notebook content
um so those are some of the
some of the ways that that cell objects
interact with these guys
um i wanted to point out the the couple
of special attachment points that we've
developed for cells
uh so the inline attachment point
is immediately following a cell
expression
and it pushes other things out of the
way so here we have
we're attaching to this cell some panel
that has a manipulate
and a button and we're attaching it at
the position inline which is immediately
following
and notice that it pushed this other
item out of the way
i'll show that again evaluate this push
the other item out of the way this is
not
so this is this is the kind of cell
attachment point that we use for the
predictive interface
you'll probably be familiar with with
that
and another useful uh handle is
the cell bracket so even when the cell
bracket is hidden
uh temporarily or permanently we know
where the cell bracket would have been
and here's an attached cell that
displays essentially a progress
indicator
or progress monitor to the bottom of the
cell
bracket so as something is running here
we have
we have an indication not in the
notebook content area but
attached to the cell bracket that
something is happening
so that's that's useful to be able to
know where the cell bracket is
uh we'll talk a little bit about that in
the future directions
slide at the end but for now let's move
on to a different attachment point so
box object box objects are a little bit
more slippery and a little bit of a
newer concept than cell objects
but the analogous definition
should be clear it's anytime you have a
reference to a bot you know you know
about the box language
and the in the wool from front end um
and we have a box object is just a
reference to a particular
rendered box um there's currently one
and only one way to get into this world
to the box object world and that is with
uh
by using evaluation box which is a
documented construct and i'd encourage
you to go look at the documentation if
you want to become more familiar with it
but essentially anytime you have an
evaluation box
the evaluation box open close evaluated
from inside
of a box so in a rendered dynamic in a
button function
and an event handler function etc it's
going to return
the box object for the box that spawned
that evaluation
it will not return the box option the
box object
uh if you just try shift enter on an
evaluation box that's a meaningless
concept
um this is not evaluating from a box
it's evaluating through the kernel main
loop
the boxes are long gone by the time this
is evaluating
so evaluation box is useful you know in
the context of boxes
and one way out of the out of the
evaluation box straight jacket is you
can walk up
the chain of boxes using parent box um
so you can look at the parent of an
evaluation box and its parent and its
parent and so on
but that's not we're not going to be
doing that here we're going to be
looking straight at evaluation boxes
here a button which does nothing but
print the evaluation box reference when
you
clicked so one nice thing about the
typeset form of box objects by the way
is that
this number is actually a button which
when clicked
will select the box that it refers to
so here we have a box object that refers
to the button box
and here we have if we do the same thing
in event handler we have a box object
that refers to
the boxes for that event handler and so
on there's a couple of other ways to do
these
but let me let me show by example some
of these
so we have first i'm going to show an
example of using button
so we have an attach cell that we're
attaching to the box
of a slider so we're taking along the
right edge of
the button we're going to attach the
left edge of a slider
um and we have evaluate this we click on
the slide
on the button and we get a slider it's
not attached to anything but it could be
and any and we're going to click it away
so that's the simplest possible
evaluation box example here's another
example that i think is kind of nice
which uh automatically it uses the
second argument of dynamic
um so it specifies a mouse down
mouse drag and mouse up events
separately
and on mouse down this is going to
attach a cell
to the slider and then while dragging
it's going to change the value of a
and on mouse up it's going to
automatically remove the attached cell
so here we have a new way to have a
labeled slider
by just using attach cell as part of the
dynamic tracking mechanism
i think that's kind of nice so
i'd like to show a couple other examples
of attaching to box objects
this is a wormhole example i mentioned
wormholes earlier
you can look up wormhole in our
documentation but you can also look up
inherit scope which is the real option
name
of the thing that you're going to want
to use when developing wormholes
here we have a dynamic list plot
and next to that list plot is a button
and what that button does
is it spawns an attached cell connected
to the button
that gives an interface for editing the
data so
in this case i click on edit data and it
spawns
a uh this interface that looks like a
grid of input fields this is a table
view
it's a construct that that we're
actively working on and we've uh
improved quite a bit for 12.2
so and i can go in here and i can edit
the values and
the eagle-eyed among you can see this
point
moving in the graph as i edit this thing
so this is an interface that's
um that's actually attached to live data
um those of you interested in table view
dayton abernathy is going to be giving a
talk about that
at noon today central daylight time so
i'd encourage you to go
check out jason's talk to learn more
about table view
and uh brett champion provided an
example
a couple of years ago and reminded me of
this example
a day ago a couple days ago where that
it's important to drive home
i think that one can have click events
even inside of graphics so here we have
a bunch of spheres and each sphere is a
button
that spawns an attached cell and in this
case what does that attach cell do well
it attaches to
the button box or i guess buttons and
graphics that's going to be a tag box
a display that indicates uh
a call out information so we evaluate
this guy
and now we this is the 3d graphic but we
can click on the spheres
and it's going to attach an
a call out that gives us ah this is fear
number two
this is fear number four this is fear
number six
um so just driving home the point that
that you know buttons and boxes can be
just about anywhere in the front end
okay so let's look at attaching to
notebook objects
why i'm i'm trusting that uh the
majority of people here
understand that notebook object what
notebook objects are
so i'm going to focus instead on why you
might want to attach to notebook objects
one common thing that we have done i
think in our cloud open save
framework occasionally we will put
informational banners at the top or
bottom of a notebook
and that's done with attached cells so
here i'm going to attach just a simple
banner
to the upper right corner of this cell
so you know giving
some some small indication sorry the
upper right corner of the notebook
of the notebook giving some indication
of something
this is just a silly little academic
example but you can imagine how this
might be useful
and again i have it automatically
disappearing on mouse click
but it could be uh persistent it could
have its own little close box in there
that does notebook delete of attach cell
i'm sorry notebook delete of evaluation
cell
but for convenience i've set things up
that way you can also have an attached
cell that takes over
the whole of the notebook display area
so here i have an example
an evaluation notebook that is going to
show a
a something at the same size as the
whole window
and attach the center of that to the
center of the window and
evaluate this and so
this this content that i've hidden
within i can eyes
is displaying a dynamic uh progress
indication
saying okay i'm doing something you need
to wait
and it's not really doing anything all
that interesting but then when it's done
it automatically discards
the attached cell so if you want to take
control away from the user you can do
that with an attached cell like that or
if you want to
make sure you get the user's attention
here's another example
which again i've hidden the details
behind iconize you can always un-iconize
to see the details
but so this is an interface that again
obscures
most of the notebook and asks the user
to focus on a particular
thing that you're communicating um i
think in web lingo this is known as a
light box
so uh so here we have the ability to to
again
make sure that the user sees some
important piece of information
right okay so we've talked about cell
objects box objects notebook objects
we've talked about some of the ways to
trigger attachments
we can trigger them trigger attached
cells we can trigger them by any uh
evaluation
obviously they can run the attach cell
function that's going to be coming in
12.2
other places that that function can be
run mountain button clicks mouse
activity dynamic updates
one i wanted to especially point out was
initialization
because initialization has been an
option to dynamic module
and other interface constructs for some
time but starting more recently
initialization is an option to
also now an option to notebook and to
sell
so if if one wanted a piece of code
run automatically say whenever a
notebook is displayed or whenever a cell
is displayed
one can now do that with the
initialization option to notebook
or to sell so here i'm going to give an
example that takes a notebook expression
so example data can return notebook
expressions this returns a notebook
expression that has
a few text cells in it corresponding to
to lincoln's address
i'm going to add an initialization
option to it
which does attach something
to that notebook and again you can see
the details by uniconizing but i will
evaluate this so you can see
what it does so it it renders
a a what you can think of i guess as a
watermark
over this notebook it attaches notice
that the
watermark moves as the notebook is is
resized and it overlays the content
um in a way that you might want for a
watermark
so you know very powerful this
initialization concept
you can also set it it's fairly common
to set it in
style sheets so if you have a cell that
you always want a particular style of
cell
to render a particular attached cell
on it you can include an initialization
setting in the style sheet
definition for that style and it'll
happen automatically
so that's triggering attachments i also
want to show
talk a little bit more about triggering
detachments we've seen a couple of
examples already
you can manually call notebook delete we
have this option
for removal conditions that lets you
specify automatically getting rid of the
attached cell
we've also mentioned i haven't i haven't
proven this to you but we've mentioned
that
these guys are automatically stripped
when saving the notebook or when you're
copying and pasting the content
we also have the attached cells are
automatically removed
when their immediate parent is deleted
so i wanted to show an example of that
and in so doing also show an example of
nested attached cells so here we start
with the same
gray box that we had earlier and we used
the initialization option of dynamic
to get the box object for that dynamic
box
so here we have a box object
corresponding to the dynamic box that
contains this gray guy
now we're going to attach to that gray
box
a red square to the right of that box
and we have a reference to that red
square
so this red square is a an attached cell
and its cell object is stored in the
variable red
we're going to attach to that cell
object a green square
so to the right of the red square will
be
a green square we have now two attached
cells
red is attached to gray green is
attached to red
and likewise we have add a third here
blue is attached to green
and green is attached to red red is
attached to gray what happens if we get
rid of
the green attached cell well the green
one itself will disappear
but also any attached cells attached to
it or attached to attached cells
attached to it will also be deleted
so if we delete the green guy then uh
then green and blue both go away if we
were attacked to delete
beat red
i guess one thing i will show you is the
copy and paste
so if i if i have an attached cell now i
just copy that
and pasted it and now we have um
and now we have uh we noticed that the
attached cell has disappeared
okay um well that brings me close to the
end
i wanted to point out that you know
there's lots of
we're planning to do lots of other nice
things with attached cells going forward
we're going to be thinking about ways to
add features
uh in the user space including renaming
things and attaching common operations
in in plain sight we'll be building out
uh features for attaching content
so we've already seen that lightbox like
example we might be
packaging that up as a as its own
feature so you don't need to
roll it yourself i also wanted to point
out
that for certain idiomatic attached
content we probably will be providing
uh convenience functions for that as
well so we have
you know we we have these ribbons that
we show in the image editor or for the
predictive interface
um wouldn't it be nice if there were
some user level way for
you all to be able to create these guys
yourself this is pseudo code
it's not in 12 2 but uh just included
for a
possible you know future direction of a
way that we might
uh that we might provide the ability to
build ribbons to users
um we're also going to think about more
ways to use box objects and to get box
objects
into into more widespread use and
you know the point of building a tax
cell in the first place is that now you
guys can take this and run with it
so that concludes my talk
if there are questions i have a couple
of minutes i think i can
make an attempt at answering them
otherwise thank you for your attention
looks like there was a question earlier
in the past will chat which was will
attach
cells work in the wolfram cloud um
yes so good question uh not all of these
features work in the cloud
uh the cloud uh has built out i mean
you've seen the pretty good interface
working in the cloud um so
attach cells to some degree work not all
of the features
of the attach cell
syntax will work in cloud on day one
but we will be we will be uh
pushing that to completion uh in the
fullness of time
it looks like there was another question
that says as i understand it
you can attach more than one cell to a
place making a tree what about
attachment loops
what about attachment loops um i don't
know how you'd close the loop
uh you can't so in other words you can
attach
an expression to an object you can't
attach an object
to an object so the attach cell function
always creates
a new leaf if you like and then attaches
it
uh to a previously existing node but
there's no way to close that circle
looks like another question there is can
we have drag and drop functionality in
notebooks for example
dragging an object from a library and
dropping onto a canvas to build a
graphics
hmm well certain number of drag and drop
things work already
those of you who've tried dragging pngs
into notebook windows
or csv files know that that import is
called automatically when dragging
things
into a notebook window specifically
dragging things and dropping them onto a
canvas
is not something i know how to
handle at the moment but i'm happy to
discuss
in the in the office hour this afternoon
if that's important to people
i'm happy to get feedback about what's
important and uh and we can talk about
what what might be possible
in the future
uh another question was asked i am
wondering if we can see the attached
cell objects
if we do a notebook get on the
evaluation notebook
ah uh so notebook get notebook read
notebook save
none of those things will get you the
attached cell
and the attached cell is not part of the
notebook model at all
it's it's just not present
and so nothing that looks at the
notebook expression
is going to see is going to show you the
attached cell
there may be some way to navigate
objects to get to the attached cell
although i don't think there are
currently um
but but there's nothing in the notebook
expression
that that will expose the attached cell
any attached cell
another question from the pathable chat
says can we attach
cells to a dot cell
um interesting question so yes you can
but uh the problem with that
is that doc cells are very limited in
their space and so you can't have an
attached cell currently
you can't have an attached cell that
spills out of the
attached to something in the dark cell
area that spills
out of the dark cell area so
in that case what you really what what
we're considering
is being able to attach something at a
position in the notebook so
referring to an element of the doc cell
not as an object in the doc cell
but as an object in the in the space of
the notebook window itself
and then that attached cell could spill
over
you know it could it could ignore the
boundary between the dark cell area
and the notebook content area and use
the full notebook window area
as its as its uh drawing space we don't
yet have a solution for that in 12-2 but
that's that's the thinking that we're
that's the direction of thinking that
we're going
so there's a follow-up question of below
and also about a slidable sidebar
i'm going to need more context to
understand that question
maybe i should switch over to my uh
i can refresh you may need to refresh
that that page looks like a little out
of date
um below and there was another question
while we're waiting for more contacts
that says uh if we print
or print to pdf will the attached cell
show up
uh interesting question i think the
answer is no
but uh i'm not sure
uh good thing to try i i think i think
[Music]
so yeah i don't know and i don't know
what i would expect there either
um so
is the question so about below can we
attach attach cells
to a dark cell below the attached cell
maybe that's the question
um and i think i've answered that in my
description of
the the limited space available to the
doc cells
slidable sidebar um i mean one could
certainly imagine
attaching something to the right or left
side of a notebook window
that gave the impression of being a
drawer
or or something like that but it's not
it would still have to be
in the direction of the notebook window
it can't it can't sort of slide out
in the other direction to give more
space out of the notebook window
yeah if anyone also wants to ask a
question verbally they can use the
raise hadn't button in their zoom and we
can give you the ability to speak
looking at the time we have about five
more minutes before the session
ends automatically so if there are any
questions uh now would be the time
okay i'll i'll remind people while we're
waiting for hands to go up
that this notebook is in the is on the
conference site for this page
um so i encourage you to grab it and uh
if for no other reason than to remember
what we talked about
and so when 12 2 finally goes out and
you see a tap cell
and all of its glory you can you can
play with these examples
especially the manipulate example which
maybe i'll just
play with since uh people don't have
other questions that's here
there was one other question in the
possible chat that says is it how
workflow pages are done
um is that how workflow pages are done
i don't know the answer to that
i mean part of the beauty of building
these technologies is that they start
they start being used by people
uh other than us other than the user
interface group to do things that we
didn't officially sanction
and that's great but it means that i
don't you know i don't have
first-hand knowledge of all the things
that people are doing with these things
the attached cell the front-end support
for attach cell has been in the product
uh for years so it's entirely possible
that some enterprising user
has learned enough to be able to do some
very interesting things with attach cell
that could be refactored in light of
this new and forthcoming kernel function
um but uh but i wouldn't necessarily
know about that
okay well i'll be around uh for the rest
of the conference if you want to direct
message me or i think i'm also part of
an office hour this afternoon
so i look forward to interacting with
you all
then thanks for your attention